we're going to begin this hour with a
high profile new campaign to combat
anti-Semitism first on CBS morning's New
England Patriots owner that of course is
Robert Kraft is investing 25 million
dollars in the stand-up to Jewish hate
campaign
ask all Americans to just say no to
anti-Semitism 2022 did you know this saw
the most anti-Semitic incidents ever
recorded in this country and while the
Jewish population makes up less than two
and a half percent they are victims of
more than half of all religious-based
hate crimes think about that for just
one moment CBS Saturday morning co-host
that's Dana Jacobs and talked with Mr
Kraft about that campaign Dana good
morning to you I know he's very
committed to this
good morning Gail he is you know Robert
Kraft is supporting this campaign with
more than just his money he's using his
voice and his platform and he's
encouraging others to do the same he
told me that he's afraid for our country
having never seen this level of
anti-Semitism in the U.S before
what if any anti-Semitism did you face
when you were growing up
we had a few scuffles like many Jews
growing up in America Robert Kraft
remembers the first time he faced
anti-Semitism I was in high school
and there was a kid he made a comment
was laced with expletives and uh dirty
Jew at the end he came very close to
being a physical fight and we both were
held back
but you know what
I wound up making a friend of that guy
you can make friends of your enemies by
dialogue education
today craft is marking a new chapter in
that dialogue announcing the stand-up to
Jewish hate campaign for which Kraft has
put up 25 million dollars I saw what
you've been posting ads like this are
part of it Hitler was right showing how
people can do their part to combat hate
I didn't teach you that at the center of
the campaign is a blue square taking up
roughly 2.4 percent of a screen the same
percentage of the U.S population made up
by Jews we're asking
all fellow Americans to use this blue
emoji on their iPhones their iPads and
where this is a symbol that they're
partnering with us and standing up
against anti-Semitism but craft no he
can't do it alone if anybody knows about
teamwork it is you and this takes a team
it takes and you know what you know when
unless everyone's pitching in
and yeah any
team sport any any business anything
you want to win at you need people from
all places and all the to pitch in and
put team first
as the owner of a storied football team
craft has made some influential friends
I've called on them and
today with the breaking of our campaign
you'll see we have a lot of influencers
very
such as
well I I mean I know this guy that used
to play quarterback that well check it
out with some of those trophies back
there check it out you'll see you'll see
but we also have a lot of good people
who will recognize that this is
something they want to partner with why
do you need it to be more than just the
Jewish population because we are so
small I think you know we did some
research and it showed that over 50
percent of Americans believe that we can
handle this problem on our own and we
know we can't the campaign Springs from
Kraft's Foundation to combat
anti-Semitism which he created after
anti-semitic rhetoric
in Charlottesville Virginia in 2017 and
the deadly 2018 attack on the Tree of
Life synagogue in Pittsburgh a big part
of the foundation's focus anti-Semitism
found online and on social media those
incidents are tracked in a Command
Center built in Gillette Stadium steps
away from Kraft's office why did you
want this so close
because I knew
I wanted to have access
and be Hands-On and check what they're
doing what they're doing is monitoring
conversations across 300 million data
sources they can see in real time spikes
and anti-semitic rhetoric and share
information with other organizations
fighting hate it's going on constantly
and there's no let up and it makes me
sad actually this is the United States
of America I mean it it shouldn't happen
here and that's the goal behind the
foundation and the stand-up to Jewish
hate campaign to stop it why are you the
right person to do this I don't know
that I'm the right person I think it's
important to show people that you're
proud of your heritage and some people
don't know I'm of Jewish Heritage well
I'm not ashamed to tell them that and
I'm proud of it
craft reminded me several times during
this interview that while this campaign
is a out anti-Semitism it affects us all
because hate like this does not stop
with those of us that are Jewish and
Tony that really resonated with me
because it reminded me of a poem that is
often referenced around the Holocaust it
is about the idea that after the
Holocaust there was so much remorse for
not speaking up uh not speaking up when
the Nazis came first for one group then
the next then the next until there was
no one else left to speak up
yeah why don't we shout it is a big deal
to see Robert Kraft stand up and say I
am Jewish and this will not stand and to
do it Dana as you so beautifully set up
in the piece with those six Lombardi
trophies behind him showing uh his
accomplishments in this life thank you
very much for that piece really
appreciate it and you know what else
matters guys is if if he can get uh
former or current NFL players to back
him in this that will go a long way to
amplifying the message this is the
oldest hatred it's often said it's a
persistent one and it's going to need
people like himself and those players I
think to get a Groundswell to say this
will not stand but he's encouraging
everybody to get involved that's what I
like about it number one I really admire
and respect what he's doing and how he's
doing it 25 million dollars is not chump
change I don't care how much money you
have the fact that he's putting that
much money in this effort and then
monitoring it we were talking about in
real time you can tell it's something
that's deeply personal to him deeply
cares and I think it's sending a very
powerful message and that blue square
idea you know I like four percent or
something of the population here all the
attention he does so much stuff outside
of the sports space exactly that he
doesn't get credit for it I'm glad that
we're highlighting this yeah all right
Dan thank you again for that